all right I just finished eating a
delicious dinner and I was about to sit
down on that extremely comfy relaxing
couch right there
and there's a freaking woman that's like
can I wear some stuff for you and then
you tell me and I'm like are you kidding
me yeah do you know how hard I work for
this family and you're gonna waste my
time looking at more stuff
so what do you want okay so um I did a
video before you weren't here where I
did a try on Haul on a bunch of going
out clothes I don't have very many going
out clothes because I don't go out very
many times
what are you doing look at my butt no
I'm looking at my beautiful face fine
um so I tried on a bunch of clothes and
I think I bought like 16 different
pieces okay I only kept two of those
things okay as I kept looking at the two
really beautiful dresses that I got I
realized that they're more daytime
dresses yeah than like going out to like
a nice restaurant and possibly a lounge
because this works out huh it's a girls
trip yes going out huh are you kidding
me it's my girlfriend's
um my girlfriend Steffy
um it's her it's her birthday I have a
girl who has a birthday too
I like this immediate obedience that's
awesome you're a good Rottweiler you
know that
okay so because of that I went back to
Asos because I love Asos and please
sponsor me already
um sponsor anybody yes some of our
friends go to the Asus stuff but it
doesn't matter because I know fashion
Nova sponsors people I know Asos anyway
so I went back to Asos got a bunch of
stuff and the reason why I love Asus and
I always say this is because it just has
a lot of different brands yeah
um so it's like me going to 20 different
stores all in one place which is why I
always go back to Asos so I went back
and I feel like I got more
appropriate nighttime clothing and I
wanted you bar just you to let me know
if it looked good and if it works
um but
now I want everyone else to chime in
cutie what happened to your legs
on your arms like his little booty socks
your little booties yeah okay outfit
number one these are meant to be
together
are you serious you don't even wear that
stuff for me that looks hot
I I didn't mean to pair this together so
this could go as separately there's side
seams you know what you look like you
look like one of the operators uh from
John Wick you know when they make the
phone call and there's all those hot
like operators in the back
hey candy guy that's funny how come you
don't even wear this for me and you
wanted this oh are you kidding me uh
yeah no I'm not I I didn't know it was
gonna be like this what do you mean you
saw it in the picture I know but usually
they're more stick figure they don't
have like this going on
you're a big funny guy
yeah that fits you perfectly can you go
all the way to the top neck just put on
it
I don't know I love about this yet my
butt butt I kind of like the skirt it's
separate
from this corset I don't like any of it
tell you that much no really because
it's too hot
you can't wear stuff the corset's not
really my thing I feel like damn look at
these bad canes though your back does
look nice
don't feel comfortable I feel like my
boobs are gonna pop out any second I
know that's what I'm saying yeah I don't
like it are you kidding me
I might think about the skirt
hey so I changed at the top I got this
one I'm not gonna wear it together but
already this feels way more comfortable
yes yeah so I think I'm Gonna Keep the
cup the top yeah and I think I'm Gonna
Keep the skirt it's so pretty look at
that it's like sexy but like classy
[Music]
how do you do that hey guys hey you look
like a cyclops yes I'm done
you know what he looks like he looks
like my wiener
it's not that long what do you mean it's
longer I know but it only has one eye
monkey
all right here's the other outfit
s yeah nice and covered up that's what
I'm talking about
yeah yeah that's good
I think you should wear this Yep this is
a good one that's the good one no no
don't don't raise your arms yep that's
that's the good one
I like it it's kind of heavy it's not
the most comfortable but
no it looks great yup it's the best one
so far really I love long skirts type of
deal if you haven't noticed yeah
hey hey you match with Mama both you
guys are like silver gray looking
keep it yeah keep this one the other
ones are hotter though so if you're
trying to look for a new man you should
wear the other one so what is this like
this one is I'm like a sexy nun or
something
sexy none
not sure I want a sexy enough
because that's crazy
on the couch
yeah okay
I'm gonna get you oh
[Music]
yeah
no too late okay
[Music]
again I said okay so a couple things
first these shoes are so painful I'm not
keeping them so I'm glad I wore them
around the house I probably only wore
them for like maybe 10 minutes
um and they are killing my feet already
so uh no thank you and then this sleeve
it won't let me get my arm through so
there's like this additional like like
inner layer yeah like the satin layer on
the inside so that I mean because it
looks so prickly so that this is not on
the inside and it's not painful and it's
not really soft on the inside
um
don't shoot over here
like uh he wasn't looking but the sleeve
on the inside is Twisted I can't even
get my arm in so it's all a sign I'm not
getting gotta return that one yeah
yeah but it was supposed to be like that
imagine the other onion
did he hit you in the face
hit my glasses for him that's a good
shot
do you compliment him no he's gonna be
in trouble are you in trouble space yeah
but then he's also a really good shot it
was I'll tell him maybe a Navy SEAL no
I'll tell him after he did a good job
are you serious what
always the hottest stuff ever
it's better heels on sometimes it looks
really good like I'm trying to pretend
like I'm working with seals are like six
three awesome let's say seals with heels
he looks really good on you yeah you
look the angel
a hot angel
that that returns money with sex
so like I borrow money but I I pay back
my debt no you're just a hooker I just
pay you and you return it with sex oh
got it
got it so then are you saying don't
don't can we keep some of these for us
yeah right yeah right what are you
talking about
okay I might just keep this one
for us yeah for us because then I can go
attack this is how your little brother
got me
back at it again Mr fleece overall
okay this one
super short it comes with shoulder pads
and I'm not a fan I didn't know it was
like this this leopard print yeah oh not
about it
and look now I look like a hooker
like a big tall big beach hooker
oh
blue heels
not sure what I mean they're not meant
to be paired together yeah but imagine
this with the bra
not so sad boobs but pants look it's
very colorful
the color palette's cool thank you yeah
I think I'm gonna keep these shoes are
way more comfortable like holy crap way
more comfortable
those look really Airy and comfy
they're legit I feel like only you could
pull them all because you're so tall I
know
because if I wanted pants like that I
would just look so dumb yeah and I think
you can only wear them too with heels
because look by itself oh oh yeah well
it still looks good on you because
you're so tall
this guy's ridiculous
he's so awesome
pretty cool
okay
super cute didn't really go with the
pants but this look at how jacked I look
make sure shoulders pop out like crazy I
know I have great shoulders you do you
have really good shoulders good
clavicles too yeah it's a little
see-through so I do have
some stuff in here but
we look good your back's looking real
good yes from all those accessories
whoa daily those rhomboids yeah yeah
sick
you're a strong mama okay yeah yeah
that'll keep all the dudes away that's
for sure
good good just do that okay is it how
buff mama is
this guy's so tired yeah okay
that jacket looks pretty good was it
really yeah you look like some like uh
like head head person like an agency
you're fired you're fired you're fired
yeah yeah yeah where are the I like a
design firm or something like that where
are the samples
[Applause]
that was my hair too you look good yeah
because your hair's all up you mean
business it's all blue but then it's
hella stylish how did I just like just
like put together a cute outfit how the
f
okay sit on my lap okay I think that's
all I got
well I do have a couple bikinis
what are you serious you have bikinis uh
swimsuits bathing suits what do you need
bikinis for a friend's birthday for
because they're the ones I bought are
way too remember we I couldn't wear
you're gonna go swimming all of a sudden
in the middle of the winter all of a
sudden go swimming babe you're gonna go
swimming all of a sudden spring we
didn't swim once we haven't swim once in
the first last six months what
what well I'm gonna go swimming with the
dudes too then we're gonna go to Cancun
yeah let me know how it goes you know
what you don't even have to check in
don't tell me anything we're gonna go
swim the Amsterdam red light district
fine okay if you had to pick any outfit
for night time this isn't night time
this is like I was gonna say that one I
know let's see you can pick this one any
of the dresses which ones did you like
the best the silver one the one that you
look like a tin can man do I really
should I return it I mean the one that
makes you look super sexy almost like a
bikini
should I return it no where'd that one
that one's the best one keeps you nice
and covered up I like it I feel like I
can use it for multiple occasions yeah
yeah keep that one everything else is no
good you're gonna be so cold all that
Skin showing you have Goosebumps no way
[Music]
daddy your mom's trying to be
promiscuous I'm not
excuse girls
are you kid
are you kidding me bikini why are you
wearing all this stuff I mean what else
are you supposed to wear at a pool all
right I'm gonna start buying Speedos and
then I'm gonna wear it out the pool I'm
gonna go to those Vegas Vegas casino
swim clubs this actually fits really
nice Peppa
[Music]
Peppa what do you think about Mama's
bikini Mouse
ah it's so spicy but I think my mama's
bikinis mama look good
blah
well Mama's finishing trying on all her
clothes for the girls trip
um filling up the bathtub with some hot
water
because I just started my volume block
today for squats meaning I'm gonna have
a max out day coming up soon probably in
like six to eight weeks and really cost
500 which is like my lifetime glove I've
always wanted to hit 500.
so I just really want to end my training
my last like six months of training with
the big bang so you really want to get a
lot of volume which is like I think
today I hit over 10 sets of squats
um at different weights different styles
like uh like a three by four a regular
then I hit some pod squats and I had
some goblet squat Solutions it's just
all different types of volume but I know
my legs are gonna be trash tomorrow so
I'm gonna speed up the recovery with a
hot bath get the circulation going glow
and get the circulation going and bring
the nutrients everywhere and my CUNY
little dude taika is so good
he's been getting really good on our
nighttime routine and usually I always
have to tell him
to go get his jammas in his underwear
but he saw me get ready for a bath and
look what he brought
he brought his CUNY little underwear oh
my god look how small is this
and then he bought his dramas
and I got his little milk
and that's the book we're gonna read
tonight
all right I've been in this super
freaking hot water
only up to like halfway as you can see
my forehead is sweating which is good
it's super hot I haven't had a hot tub
in a long time so I was kind of being
like a little pansy when getting in it I
remember like back when we used to have
the hot tub in our house in LA
I was getting into it like every single
day so it could be at like a hundred and
I just jump in like it's nothing but I
don't even know if I had it at 100 or
whatever that but I had like
get in but then now that I'm in oh it
feels so good
and I purposely didn't fill it up all
the way because
I actually have a heavy bench tomorrow
so the the pros of a hot bath
is that it relaxes you it's great for
recovery
and it helps
um you like rest and recuperate and do
all the good stuff
the bat the calm to it is that it does
loosen up your muscles because one
you're in water so it's an anti-gravity
environment and then number two the
warmth like lengthens or muscles and you
don't want to do that before a heavy
lift that which I'm only doing my lower
body
because I've actually tried it like like
for me even though I I go to like
seminars and I learn from the the top
coaches and the top athletes but I still
have to try to know how it feels and I
have like deadlifted and squatted after
a hot tub session before and your legs
just feel like noodles like your lower
back feels like noodles and I'm like
okay
these guys uh their 30 years of
experience
is not to be messed with so I'm only
just doing my lower body hopefully it
doesn't affect my bench tomorrow I got a
big bench everything in my training is
going really good this year so I'm
really happy
um if you guys wanna
stay in tune with my lifting like
specifically make sure you go to the
bottle Brigade YouTube channel that's
where it documents it the best and also
make sure you check out barbell
brigade.com that's where you can get
supplements apparel for coming out with
a bunch of programs this year like a get
lean program ironically I am bigger but
I have gotten lean before so I'm sharing
some of my secrets from uh the uh the
last couple of years how I was able to
get uh more shredded
but yeah now it's time for me to get out
and I have to close the camera to see my
shriveled up nets
in the middle of putting taika to sleep
she wasn't paying attention so of course
he takes the big cup of water which I'm
actually impressed is really strong but
he just took it and he drank it and he
passed it back to Mama without looking
and he spilled so we have that whole
freaking blanket
good thing my bear has another comforter
so we're getting this and I was gonna
take off the cover but it is dry ass
Vegas I wouldn't be surprised if this
was completely
dry by tomorrow
and I don't know how mober always does
this but she's always the first to bet
did you even brush your teeth I'm
whitening my teeth
so you get this comfy only to get out of
bed later no I
have way too much because there's times
we get so comfy and you have contacts
and everything you stop like 10 other
things you need to do before you get to
bed I know I know my life sucks
why do you do that I don't know I try to
avoid getting in the comfiest place in
the world until I'm completely done see
look at this look at my jammas brush my
teeth already took a shower now if I get
in here I don't have to get out
but
you still have clothes on somebody got
your glasses on still gotta do your
teeth thing
I can almost guarantee you I know it's
gonna happen you're gonna go on your
phone because you're supposed probably
got like 10 15 20 minutes
and then you're gonna be tired it's
because you're so melted into the bed it
doesn't like pull that stuff off
and then like [ __ ] it I'm just gonna go
sleep just like this there's too much
gel roses do it's yucky
I like how literally at the beginning of
this Vlog you're the hottest creature in
the world and now you're this ogre
and this is why when I think number two
why you're making you know oh you know I
think you're beautiful the most
beautiful woman in the world you're
talking all that [ __ ]
you're the one with the freaking plastic
teeth on
all right so
it's sounding big baby number two as you
can tell I can read the science
oh yeah
Prime she's a real Pride she can't wait
see you guys tomorrow